the Joe Rogan experience I need to ask
you about some certain [ __ ] like what do
you think about the John Jones situation
like with John Jones
testing positive but saying was a
tainted supplement what you think about
all that I think s it okay I'll go back
all the way back window you could do
pretty much anything you wanted right
right I brought my own bread on food
everything to Japan if I would go to a
halt I will bring my own water I
wouldn't drink the water they had there
I've heard all the war stories and
fighting in foreign countries that they
might taint it or something to do
something make sure every product that
you take as a professional athlete is
your responsibility you know so once
that happens and I thought that thing
that suppling wasn't that the same thing
to supplement as your Romero had I
believe it was that same thing to remand
they have the same manager so so their
manager didn't say hey wait a minute Joe
Romero maybe you shouldn't take this
because I don't know 100 percent here
I'm just talking at anyway even if
that's not the case as a manager you
would say I think from now on you should
buy only products that are on a list
they don't do anything else any more
just to make sure because people you
know where the smoke is fire that's what
people think it's always like Ethel
forty I was very happy with y'all Romero
when he when he brought a product I say
that's the first guy who actually does
that right they took the product got it
off the market because it wasn't there
and he was cleared I said okay finally I
would have done means did the same thing
Tim means tested positive and then he
fired it also they found it on the shelf
they did an independent test of it and
they said yup it's in this stuff that's
a real common thing a lot of baseball
players were tested positive for the
exact same thing that John tested for
apparently it's in a bunch of different
supplements but you get it in trace
elements or trace amounts you know
you're not getting like big amounts and
a lot of it comes from they take the
same vats in you know China wherever
they make that [ __ ] and they'll make
some steroids and then their way in and
out but do a shitty job of cleaning it
out and then they'll make some creatine
and that's like the gluten free products
you know but sometimes they use a
machine that you have spread it with
gluten in there right and it's painted
just like that yeah it definitely can be
it definitely can be you know I've heard
a bunch of crazy stories one of the the
craziest one was they think that
cocaine sometimes they cut with creatine
and creatine is often infected with this
steroid that it's often tainted because
your you know you're getting cheap
creatine from China and they use
creatine to cut cocaine with I got a
good idea don't do cocaine if you're a
fighter just crazy that didn't even make
sense don't do coke when can he come
back when it come back Joe I don't know
I don't think they've done his hearing
yet oh man what a talent what a waste
you know they did the California hearing
but I think the Nevada State Athletic
Commission and you sada I think that's
in April sometime I think it's this I
really hope we're gonna see him soon I
really hope he turns his life alright I
truly the best yeah he's the best I mean
the impact that he can have on kids and
on everything going out as if he trains
for for it fights four more years
yeah just beat everybody I think oh I I
think he can still do it too you still
come back and maybe you know hopefully
it's clear
one thing is clear from his test is that
whatever he took was a tiny trace amount
and it must have been accidental must
have been this is according to Jeff
Novitzky
because if you look at right before that
test he tested negative he test positive
for the tiniest amount and then he tests
negative again right afterwards yes she
is it tiny so it has to be an accident
and it definitely didn't have any
performance enhancing benefit
well the levels that he took they're
talking about trace amount but you see
this is where comes in play what he did
before and that's why he's getting
penalized you see so you're responsible
for your actions that's what's happening
idle to which is so crazy I know but you
know if somebody has the chance to do it
back what a comeback that will be I
think he can do it he can a hundred
percent I mean you think about his wit
his victory over Daniel Cormier the way
he did it
that left high kick and then puts it
away he set it up yeah entire fight he
was setting it up yeah and I think that
when he came back and the before the
loss break that I said okay now he can
let it fly I think you set him up enough
yeah I love that men making a pattern
and then breaking to better and that's I
love that style of fighting yeah
and I mean he's such a talent I mean and
just but isn't it funny how some of
those guys that are so talented are also
so self-destructive so common it's
because oh no no but it's not only that
it's it's talented and because the
talent that propels them up in the
limelight and suddenly they become
somebody and it's like I said with
Connor you got all the a said nobody
says no to you right and if you have
that constantly 24/7 around you yeah you
start becoming do you think you're God
you can start doing things that other
people can and you can that's the worst
part I mean you look I mean he didn't go
to jail
think about it what he did right hitting
the woman and then the drugs out of the
car and the woman was pregnant that she
was injured I mean there's a serious
thing a normal person would have been in
jail right so and with the money
situation and how he changed suddenly
with cormier one day well you know where
where they filmed them at the interview
and they they kept it rolling and they
didn't know they were wrong and he
started saying how much money you have I
got so much more money I got this I get
this and I go dude what are you doing
what is it's a way a thing to say but
then again you think of it is the he was
the youngest champ you know so ever
right I mean the guy is young I mean I
was an idiot I thought I was an idiot
when I started at 28 grown up completely
crazy so that's why I never blame people
because I know I wasn't complete idiot
right well you have a great perspective
on it because of that yeah yeah you've
been there you know what it's like and
you were a [ __ ] wild man and now
you're very calm except for when you
occasionally quantitate oh yeah 13 hours
is too long for a commercial [ __ ] don't
do that I know what that's like though
they keep on wanting you do it again you
get angry like [ __ ] ya know it's an ego
thing too because they said it's fine
but because they said would be good you
know that now it's in my head I go I
just want to do it for them so I don't
feel as bad as I go am i right it's just
pushing it it's just saying no little
sooner that's the trick
[Applause]